NARRATOR: They created
a ship of dreams.
Phil Gowan: It had to be the
ultimate climax of their lives.
NARRATOR: But for nine
shipbuilders aboard the Titanic,
the dream became a nightmare.
And the nightmare...became
a commodity.
One hundred years later, a
global market for all things
Titanic leaves the
ship itself exposed.
Bob Ballard: The Titanic is
really a deep sea museum with
the doors wide open.
Fred Parkes: That's
my uncle's graveyard,
and you don't desecrate a grave.
NARRATOR: National Geographic
explorer-in-residence
Robert Ballard discovered
the ship 27 years ago.
Now he fears the Titanic
will be lost...again
Bob Ballard: If the
Titanic is not protected,
it'll get stripped until all
the jewels have been taken off
the old lady's body.
NARRATOR: The Titanic is
a dark and silent grave.
Here, every object
tells a story...of
triumph...luxury...and loss.
Even the humblest artifacts
fuel a legend that captivates
millions around the world.
Auctioneer: Lot 164, a brown
wisteria chocolate cup in mint
condition, and I'm in
at 350 on this one...
Nikki: She was just
such an amazing ship.
The thought that within a few
days she just disappeared to
the ocean lost forever...
Engineer: I'm an
engineer by trade,
so I'm interested
in the mechanical,
in how the ship works.
Collector: Of the
things I collect,
I think the things that
interest me pertain to people.
Auctioneer: ...at
75 pounds, 75, 75...
NARRATOR: This is where
collectors put a price tag
on the global fascination
with the Titanic.
Auctioneer: Eight
hundred pounds!
NARRATOR: Twice a year, Titanic
enthusiasts descend on a small
town in the English countryside
to visit the auction house of
Henry Aldridge & Son.
Andrew Aldridge: We are the
world's leaders in the sale
of Titanic memorabilia.
We have sold hundreds
and hundreds of items.
We hold every world record
relating to the sale
of Titanic memorabilia.
These tiles will cost three
or four hundred pounds.
Here is a remarkable item worth
between two or three thousand
pounds.
Something like this will be
worth between three and five
thousand pounds.
This card was posted
from the Titanic.
So, this card is worth
several thousand pounds.
NARRATOR: One of the most
anticipated items in the auction
is a set of keys from a
first class men's lavatory.
Andrew Aldridge: And what's
significant about these,
they're from the Titanic.
So they're worth between
30 and 50,000 pounds.
Auction Visitor: Can I have
a look at the large plate?
NARRATOR: It all comes down
to what collectors are willing
to bid to own a piece
of Titanic's history.
Auctioneer: Starting
at 120 pounds.
Andrew Aldridge: We have phone
bids registered from around
the world.
We got bids from U.S.,
bidders from China,
bidders from Thailand.
Nikki: I particularly
collect menus.
John: The china is
my main interest.
I've always collected the china.
Save my pennies and then spend
them all and then save my
pennies and then spend them all.
Alan: They've got some
fantastic stuff in the auction.
One off things, which will
probably never appear again,
and I suspect items like that
will just go through the roof.
NARRATOR: As a
reputable auction house,
Aldridge & Son carefully
researches the origins of every
artifact-and never deals
in objects recovered from
the ocean floor.
But in such a lucrative market,
serious Titanic collectors know
there's a dark side.
Nikki: I think people have
always been interested in
the idea of going down and
retrieving objects from
the debris field.
NARRATOR: And the
threat is real.
John: Someone said something
once about a rivet that someone
offered them for about
10,000 pounds from a wreck.
As long as you got proof
that it is from the Titanic,
you can name your price.
NARRATOR: A black market in
Titanic artifacts is a nightmare
scenario for Dr. Robert Ballard.
Bob Ballard: The Titanic is
really a deep sea museum with
the doors wide open.
There's no lock on the
door, and there's no guard.
NARRATOR: Ironically, much
of today's fascination with
the Titanic stems from Ballard's
discovery of the shipwreck
in 1985.
What is that? The boiler!
Bob Ballard: The boiler for me
was the signature image that
told us we'd found the Titanic.
Go rouse everybody out
of the racks. Wake the ship.
Bob Ballard: There were
two people inside of me
at that moment.
The professional, who was
elated and happy and excited.
But then there was the human
inside of me that was the exact
opposite feeling.
A sense of remorse.
A sense of, oh, we shouldn't
be celebrating anything.
We're at the spot where
this amazing tragedy,
this amazing drama had unfolded.
NARRATOR: Dr. Ballard's
discovery unleashed an explosion
of interest in the Titanic,
attracting tourists and treasure
hunters to the site.
According to the law of the sea,
Ballard and his team could have
claimed the Titanic as their own
property by removing a single
artifact.
Bob Ballard: When we
found the Titanic,
it wouldn't have been that
difficult to go back and pick up
something...but after
a lot of thought,
we decided not to
disturb the site.
NARRATOR: Two years later, RMS
Titanic Inc., a for-profit
company, mounted the first
of many salvage operations.
The Titanic has even become
a tourist destination.
Tourist 1: It was very
sad, but very beautiful,
and it was very
emotional for me.
Tourist 2: It's something I've
wanted to do my whole life.
Seen all the pictures, but
nothing compares to seeing
it when you're right there.
NARRATOR: For the lucky
few who can afford
the 60, 000-dollar fee, visitors
can board Russian subs and dive
to the shipwreck.
With each visit, the
Titanic pays a price.
Bob Ballard: Right there.
See those big orange...that's
where the submarines have been
landing and you can see it's
just,it's breaking down the deck
It's crushing it.
When you see orange, that's a
freshly exposed surface and
that's not natural.
That's being done by the people
coming and loving the thing
to death.
NARRATOR: With no international
agreements in place to protect
the ship, Ballard sees
dramatic changes since 1985.
Bob Ballard: The Titanic
is becoming a junk yard.
You'll see big piles of chain
and big bags and, you know,
there's a lot of
trash down there.
Up here, we're now going up
traversing the mast and when
we found it, it
had a crow's nest.
NARRATOR: In
Ballard's first dives,
he filmed the crow's nest where
lookouts spotted the iceberg
that doomed the Titanic.
Now, that crucial piece
of history...is gone,
apparently knocked into a cargo
hold by a passing submarine.
Bob Ballard: It's really sad
when I look at the damage that's
been done by the submarines.
We, in many ways,
opened Pandora's box.
If the Titanic is not protected
and there's no guard on duty,
it'll get stripped.
It'll get stripped until all
the jewels have been taken off
the old lady's body.
NARRATOR: On the 100th
anniversary of the Titanic
disaster, Ballard is on
a quest to save the ship-before
it's too late.
Bob Ballard: So we're gonna
actually begin where it was
built, up here in
northern Ireland.
What I want to do is to
reconstruct the real story
of the Titanic-from its
birthplace in Belfast,
to its final destination
in New York City.
NARRATOR: And he wants to hear
directly from the families of
an elite team of Titanic heroes:
Men who designed the
ship...built her with their own
hands...and were selected to
sail on her maiden voyage.
To track down their families,
Ballard will rely on an
international network of
researchers...including a
Titanic buff who doesn't
collect artifacts
he collects passengers.
Phil Gowan: I have all 2208
people that were on Titanic
listed in here.
Their birth certificates, their
death certificates, their wills,
their immigration
papers, passports.
NARRATOR: Phil Gowan's interest
in the Titanic began at
an early age.
Phil Gowan: I can remember
very clearly my mother saying,
That boat sank 50
or 60 years ago.
Why do you care about it now?
I guess I wanted to know what
caused certain people to survive
and others to lose their lives.
NARRATOR: Deep in Gowan's
research is information on
the men charged with making sure
the Titanic's maiden voyage went
smoothly.
They were called
the guarantee group.
Phil Gowan: And in that group
you had a master electrician,
fitters, plumbers, draftsmen.
They were checking to see that
everything that they had put
together was
according to design.
NARRATOR: Bob Ballard comes to
the city that these men called
home, where the Titanic
first rose to life: Belfast,
northern Ireland.
Bob Ballard: Well, the Titanic
story begins in Belfast.
This was a community of
shipbuilders and built some
of the greatest ships of all.
NARRATOR: A century ago, this
dry dock was the largest on
the planet, built for an epic
new class of ocean liner.
Here tens of thousands
constructed the most massive
moving objects ever built,
including a ship they knew as
yard number 401.
History remembers
her by another name.
Bob Ballard: Everything
about the Titanic is titanic.
There's nothing small.
Everything is huge.
Just look at this.
This is where they installed
the massive propellers.
They would have been right in
front of me, three of them,
gigantic blades that
are now on the bottom
of the North Atlantic.
At the end of that dock,
I saw this wall of steel and
it just reminded me of the
moment I saw the Titanic.
And it was a flashback to
the moment of discovery.
This was built from
the same steel,
the same rivets-that's
the side of the Titanic.
This is the first thing
I saw, the side of the ship.
It was just monumental because
you can't see very far under
the ocean.
And so you're exploring this
vast part of our planet with
a flashlight.
And so you're shining your
flashlight and then all of
a sudden something
comes into view.
That really speaks to me.
More so than anything.
NARRATOR: Yet rivets and steel
are only part of the story.
Getting to the heart of the
Titanic tragedy means finding
the men who risked everything
to save Belfast's greatest
creation.
Bob Ballard has come to
northern Ireland to explore
Titanic's past.
But his real concern is
the shipwreck's future.
Bob Ballard: Ever since humans
have built great things like
the pyramids of Giza or
the tombs of the Maya,
looters have been
there the next day.
NARRATOR: Evidence presented
to a federal court suggests an
unauthorized expedition to the
Titanic took place in 2002...
and experts worry that more
rogue groups have plans for 2012
Bob Ballard: Now that we're
moving away from using manned
vehicles to ROVs, there are
thousands of them and they're
in the hands of private people.
So now the ball
game has changed.
The Titanic's at greater
peril now than ever before.
NARRATOR: If the Titanic is
plundered for her artifacts,
the impact might be felt most
in her home town of Belfast.
This was the home of
the guarantee group,
a team of workers who built
the Titanic and would sail on
her maiden voyage.
Bob Ballard: For these men,
creating the Titanic was
the pinnacle of a
decade's-long process.
And it all happened here, at the
shipyards of Harland and Wolff.
Bruce Beveridge: At one point
Harland and Wolff was the ship
builder to the world.
Now there was other companies
that were just as good.
But Harland and Wolff was
probably known best of all for
being an all around shipyard.
In other words, the majority of
the fittings on their ships were
built right on site.
NARRATOR: Harland and Wolff had
an exclusive agreement to build
ships for the White Star Line,
manufacturing almost every part
of great ocean liners-from their
steel hulls to their elaborate
interiors.
Bruce Beveridge: White Star Line
and Harland and Wolff were just
incredible ship builders.
Those two changed the way
people travel across the ocean.
Every ship that you see now has
got inspiration from Harland
and Wolff on it, whether
they know it or not.
NARRATOR: One worker at Harland
and Wolff was a young man
who would be forever linked to
the Titanic: Thomas Andrews.
Phil Gowan: Thomas Andrews was
a well-connected young man.
His uncle was Lord Pirrie,
who was in effect the owner
of Harland and Wolff.
Andrews was an
apprentice at first,
and worked his way through
various departments and got
a taste for the whole
shipbuilding industry.
NARRATOR: Soon, Thomas
was a rising star,
and his uncle put
him in charge of the design
of new ocean liners
Bruce Beveridge: It's
nepotism to the nith degree.
However, in this instance, this
man was qualified for the job.
Everybody loved Thomas Andrews,
they called him Tommy.
He was a very personable man.
He would walk around
in the shipyard,
he would talk to the workers,
he would actually listen to them
and try to do
something for them.
NARRATOR: Andrews found himself
on the leading edge of a
cutthroat industry.
In an age when airplanes and
automobiles were in their
infancy, the steamship was king.
Phil Gowan: In order to be the
most competitive business out
there in trans-Atlantic
shipping,
you wanted to have the
state-of-the-art elevators,
telephones had come into
the rooms in some of them.
These were things that were
going to lure customers away
from the competition.
NARRATOR: The first decade of
the 20th century saw an ocean
liner arms race between the
White Star Line and Cunard.
Cunard took a commanding lead
in 1907 with the Mauretania and
Lusitania, the largest and
fastest ships on earth.
White Star struck back with
ships 100 feet longer and
unparalleled in luxury...
with elaborate smoking rooms,
gymnasiums and heated
swimming pools.
The first ship in this new
class would be called Olympic.
The second, Titanic.
Bruce Beveridge: With
the Olympic and Titanic,
they really outdid Cunard and
they went way over the top.
Their ships were so big that
they had a problem finding a
harbor in order to dock them in
because nothing was deep enough.
NARRATOR: Building these ships
in Belfast meant building
a whole new infrastructure.
Bob Ballard: To come here
is to feel the Titanic.
Because you can see where it was
built, where it was outfitted,
and there's a tremendous amount
associated with the building
of the ship here.
NARRATOR: Like the offices
of the man who oversaw
the construction of the
Titanic: Thomas Andrews.
Bob Ballard: He's the architect.
He's the most qualified person
and the most knowledgeable
person about the Titanic.
I have the greatest
respect for him.
To actually be in his room in
Belfast at Harland and Wolff
is pretty special.
Pretty special.
I can imagine him standing
here, fire burning,
pondering the plans.
Seeing something that's wrong
and correcting something.
Probably had a pen right
here and made his notes,
and rolled them up and
carried them across the hall.
This was the place
where they built it.
This is her, as far as I'm
concerned, her true home.
NARRATOR: As the design and
construction of the Titanic got
underway, thousands of Belfast
workers were also competing for
a rare honor: the chance to join
Thomas Andrews on the ship's
guarantee group.
Bruce Beveridge: They all had
their specialties, you know?
They didn't just pick four guys
at Harland and Wolff and say,
Hey, you want to go for a ride?
NARRATOR: Only eight workers out
of more than ten thousand would
be chosen for the maiden voyage,
with the ninth, Thomas Andrews,
as their leader.
It was the honor of a lifetime.
Bob Ballard: The guarantee
group were the experts;
they knew the Titanic
better than anyone.
The White Star Line and the
crew were just taking over the
operation of the Titanic,
but the guarantee group were
the ones that built it.
NARRATOR: Bob Ballard has
tracked down the descendant
of one guarantee group member.
They've come to what was once
Harland and Wolff's design
department, the drawing offices
where draftsmen planned out
the entire ship...by hand.
Deirdre: Roderick Chisholm, who
was chief draftsman and part
of the guarantee group, was
my great-grandfather.
Roderick was the right
hand man of Thomas Andrews.
Bob Ballard: He was
number two, yeah.
Deirdre: Yes, I was told that
nobody knew the ship better than
Thomas Andrews and
Roderick Chisholm.
NARRATOR: In this room, Andrews
and Chisholm oversaw the designs
for Olympic and Titanic.
Bruce Beveridge: I find it just
incredible that these men,
without the use of
calculators or electronics,
could build something like this.
There's so many calculations
and there's so much work.
You know, they didn't have a
tape measure that measured out
882 feet, 9 inches.
Deirdre: Harland and Wolff
didn't just build the ship;
they fitted her out.
So it just shows you what
we Belfast people are like.
Bob Ballard: Yes.
Deirdre: Say that
with great modesty.
Bob Ballard: That was...
Deirdre: We were a
talented bunch in Belfast.
Bob Ballard: ...quite
a ship you built.
Deirdre: And I think, you know,
Titanic, it was a disaster,
and it was a tragedy,
and it was awful.
But she was magnificent.
And she spoke of what
Belfast is, magnificent.
NARRATOR: As chief draftsman
of this tremendous endeavor,
Roderick Chisholm
was a natural choice to sail
on the maiden voyage.
Deirdre: How they
chose that group...
Bob Ballard: They probably
took the best of the best....
Deirdre: Well, I'm
assuming they did.
But I mean, that would've
been an awesome honor and a,
and a real privilege.
Bob Ballard: To
be in that group.
Deirdre: To be in that group.
NARRATOR: Chisholm played
another key role-designing
the Titanic's lifeboats.
But he didn't have a say
in the number of lifeboats.
Thomas Andrews
requested as many as 64.
Bruce Beveridge: He wanted
more lifeboats in this ship.
He made an argument for it and
of course he was shot down.
NARRATOR: The heads of Harland
and Wolff and the White Star
Line wanted more deck
space and less clutter.
They insisted on no more than
20 lifeboats-four more than
the legal minimum.
It would be a fateful decision
for everyone on board.
Auctioneer: Interested
in this lot?
A black and white photograph
of Titanic's launch.
Somewhere in the
region of six sterling.
NARRATOR: Bidding is intense
at the auction in England,
as collectors compete for
artifacts from Titanic's
home town.
Auctioneer:At seven-thousand-six
at seven-thousand-six.
Am I done? Yes, I am.
Andrew Aldridge: What we've got
is a collection of material
relating to Belfast.
Belfast was the
home of the Titanic.
It was where Titanic was built,
it was where she spent all
of her life.
This is a young
man, Johnny Kelly.
He was a worker at
Harland and Wolff.
He was one of the first
men to die on Titanic.
He died in June, 1910.
He fell from the gantry, age 19,
almost two years before she sank
beneath the North Atlantic.
We have one of Titanic's rivets.
Never made it onto Titanic.
One of over three
million from the ship.
And finally, two letters
relating to the guarantee group,
men who were on the Titanic,
employed by Harland and Wolff,
to ensure that the elements
of the ship worked.
If there was an
electrical issue,
if there was a plumbing issue,
these specialists would be
on hand to solve this problem.
NARRATOR: Bob Ballard is piecing
together the story of the
guarantee group, with the help
of ancestry.com and the Belfast
Titanic Society.
He's come to the village of
Comber-ancestral home of the
group's leader, Thomas Andrews.
Bob Ballard: I remember when I
was first thinking about trying
to find her, and I thought
immediately of Thomas Andrews
because that was the person
I, in all my research,
I had the deepest respect for.
Johnny: Yes, and we're now
celebrating that great
achievement.
Not just by one man-Uncle
Tommy-but by all his work mates.
Bob Ballard: When you look at
the state of the technology
and the shipbuilding, it was
really the cutting edge.
Johnny: Yes, it was at the
pinnacle of technology,
at the peak of
the British empire.
It was an exciting time and
Belfast was at the forefront
of all that.
NARRATOR: But some have said
there's a fatal flaw in Thomas
Andrews' design of the Titanic.
To find out, Ballard has come
to a conservation lab outside
Belfast to examine the
original ship plans.
NARRATOR: They've never
been filmed before.
William Blair: We are fortunate
to be the repository for
the Harland and Wolff
ship plan collection,
which includes the original
designs for Olympic and Titanic.
Bob Ballard: Well, this is a
very familiar drawing to me.
I see the forward mast and the
crow's nest and the ship's bell.
This drawing here
of the poop deck,
the after section of the Titanic
really for me has such symbolism
because as the bow went down,
people just kept progressing
backwards and
backwards to the stern.
Then finally they came to
where there was nowhere to go.
They just jumped.
Jumping in most
cases to their death.
NARRATOR: One
hundred years later,
experts still want to know if
the Titanic was a ticking time
bomb, her fate written
into her plans.
The answer might lie in
Titanic's twin sister,
built from the same set
of drawings: the Olympic.
Bruce Beveridge: This has caused
a lot of confusion over time and
as you can see from the profiles
here-this is the Olympic
and this is the Titanic.
Unless you knew what
you were looking at,
you would confuse
one for the other.
NARRATOR: While almost
identical on paper,
Titanic and Olympic had
strikingly different careers.
William Blair: Olympic really
had the career in a sense
that Titanic would have had...
Bob Ballard: Yeah, it had
hundreds of crossings.
William Blair: ...had it
not met its tragic fate.
NARRATOR: The Olympic was
known as old reliable,
with over 20 years of
distinguished service.
Built from the same plans,
the Titanic should have lasted
at least as long.
Bruce Beveridge: There were
no design flaws in that ship.
That ship was built to withstand
any of the stresses and strains
that are brought on, even by the
heaviest North Atlantic gales
It was not designed
to sideswipe icebergs.
William Blair: As they
used to say in Belfast,
she was all right
when she left us.
NARRATOR: And she
was in good hands.
As the Titanic rose above
the Belfast skyline,
Thomas Andrews was joined on the
guarantee group by the best and
brightest at Harland and Wolff:
Among them, chief draftsman,
Roderick Chisholm...
...electrician, William Parr...
...and Artie Frost,
a master fitter,
whose family still keeps
the tools of his trade.
Ian Frost: I have an item here
that belonged to my grandfather.
And this whistle was a
most useful thing to have,
because when you were down at
Harland and Wolff's in those
days, riveting was a
very, very noisy job.
If you wanted to draw somebody's
attention to the fact you wanted
to speak to them, you used the
whistle because they wouldn't
a heard you if you shouted.
Still works, can I use it?...
NARRATOR: In 1912, Artie Frost
got word that he'd been chosen
to represent his department
on the guarantee group.
Ian Frost: Not everybody got
sent in the guarantee group and
an awful lot of the employees
would have loved to have gone.
NARRATOR: Rounding out this
distinguished group was
engineer, Robert Knight, and
four up and coming apprentices,
including a 21-year-old
named Francis Parkes.
Fred Parkes: My uncle,
he was a plumber.
And he was 21 when he
was on the Titanic,
and he came out as
a top apprentice.
And he was selected
to go on this group...
Bob Ballard: So it
was a great honor.
Fred Parkes: A great honor
to go on this, to be on this,
this ship.
Bob Ballard: And so, when
did you first-I mean,
as soon as you were born, I
imagine, or can remember,
it must have entered your life,
the story of the Titanic.
Fred Parkes: Oh, well, it
was something that you-it was
a tragedy that you
didn't talk about.
Bob Ballard: Right. Well,
was it an embarrassment?
Fred Parkes: It was an
embarrassment, yes.
Bob Ballard: The sinking of
the Titanic was a tremendous
embarrassment to the city of
Belfast, to Harland and Wolff,
to the very heart of this
community and was not something
they wanted to talk about.
NARRATOR: Yet when
Titanic was ready to sail,
she was the toast of Belfast.
Thomas Andrews and the rest of
the guarantee group boarded the
ship on April 2nd, 1912, bound
for Southampton and ultimately
New York.
Phil Gowan: I can only guess
what Thomas Andrews and the
guarantee group might have felt
when they first stepped aboard.
But satisfaction is
what it had to be,
because nothing had ever
been like this before.
And the fact that it had been
conceived, drafted, constructed,
and now it was a
finished product,
had to be the ultimate climax
for their lives at that point
NARRATOR: The Titanic took
on passengers and crew at
Southampton, eight days
after leaving its birthplace
in Belfast.
As the journey began, the
guarantee group set to work
inspecting all
aspects of the ship,
from the engine
room to the bridge,
and from the four kitchens to
the luxurious dining rooms.
Until the fifth night at sea...
April 14th, 1912: Titanic
steaming at 22 knots...a quiet
Sunday night interrupted by the
sound of an iceberg tearing into
the ship.
At this critical moment, Captain
Edward Smith turns to the man
who knows the Titanic best.
Bob Ballard: When
they hit the iceberg,
Captain Smith summoned
Thomas Andrews.
The captain asked him to
go below decks and assess
the damage to the ship
which he knew so well.
And he went below decks and
walked the compartments and
returned to the bridge and told
the captain it was gonna sink.
NARRATOR: Despite being designed
with 16 watertight compartments,
Andrews knew that no
ship is truly unsinkable.
Bruce Beveridge: Titanic was
built to a two-compartment
standard.
We could have any of these two
compartments flooded-whether it
be this one and this one,
or this one and this one-and
she would be able to sail back
to port without a problem.
You could even have the first
four watertight compartments
flooded at the same time
and it wouldn't be an issue.
However, you can't damage one,
two, three, four and five.
That was a death
knell to the ship.
What happens is there
is too much weight.
And if you have too many
watertight compartments flooded,
the ship's gonna sink.
NARRATOR: Soon after Andrews
broke the news to the captain,
the outside world got its first
clue that Titanic was in danger.
Phil Gowan: You had the wireless
for the first time on some of
these ships.
And they began to get word
that something was up.
NARRATOR: Distress calls
emanated from the greatest
ship on the ocean.
Phil Gowan: People couldn't
believe their ears.
They thought no, this
has gotta be a mistake.
Surely that ship couldn't sink.
NARRATOR: In
Titanic's home town,
families of the ship's guarantee
group waited anxiously for word.
Ian Frost: Rumors in Belfast
were rife at the time.
And my grandmother must have
been a very worried person
because she had heard
the Titanic had sank.
She had also heard the Titanic
had been towed into port without
loss of life.
And she didn't know for three
or four days whether her husband
was alive or dead.
NARRATOR: The news
came first to New York.
Bob Ballard: This was Titanic's
destination-the goal of hundreds
of immigrants on board, and the
home of many of the ship's rich
and famous.
NARRATOR: The White Star Line
offices at the southern tip of
Manhattan now became the focal
point of the Titanic drama.
Bob Ballard: Well, right behind
me is Bowling Green Park at
the tip of Manhattan Island.
Right across the street here
at the end of Broadway is where
the White Star Line had
their headquarters.
This is where the reports
started coming in that
the Titanic had hit an
iceberg on April 14th.
But by late on the 15th, the
true story began to unfold.
NARRATOR: An ocean liner called
the Carpathia had come to the
Titanic's rescue, but they
arrived too late to the save
the ship.
Instead, they picked up
lifeboats filled with survivors,
and sent lists of names
to New York by radio.
Bob Ballard: They started
posting the names of the
survivors and the family members
came to find out if their
relatives and friends lived
or died on the Titanic.
Imagine the trickle of people
that began to assemble in this
park and then it just
got bigger and bigger.
Hundreds and hundreds of people
assembling here directly across
the street wondering.
Some went up, read
the good news,
a lot never saw the name they
hoped for and went away in tears
NARRATOR: The scene repeated
itself on both sides of
the Atlantic.
As each new name
went on the list,
a family would breathe
a sigh of relief.
Yet days later, there was still
no word on the nine men of
the guarantee group.
The rescue ship Carpathia
arrived in New York on the night
of April 18th, 1912, packed with
hundreds of Titanic survivors.
Phil Gowan: It was a mob scene.
There were people's names that
were included as having died
that actually had
survived and vice versa.
So people discovered for the
first time that night what it
really happened.
NARRATOR: As survivors
told their stories,
they began to shed light on the
leader of the guarantee group:
Thomas Andrews.
Bruce Beveridge: Thomas
Andrews was, you know,
trying to assist in getting
the life jackets out.
There is testimony that, you
know, that he told one woman,
you know, here's your life
jacket, take it and go.
NARRATOR: He didn't
heed his own advice.
Phil Gowan: Thomas Andrews was
seen in the first class smoking
room towards the end.
He was standing beside a big
painting that was above
the fireplace, and he was
staring out into the distance.
Bob Ballard: He
gave up his life.
He didn't even bother
to put on a life jacket.
He didn't even bother to
go up to the boat deck.
He was last seen admiring his
ship and went down with her.
NARRATOR: And the rest
of the guarantee group?
Artie Frost and William Parr
were last seen in the ship's
engine room, likely fighting
to keep the lights on so more
passengers could escape.
Bob Ballard: The guarantee group
I'm sure were very involved
in the final moments
of the Titanic,
because they were the ones
that truly understood what had
happened to the ship and
were trying to do their best
to save her.
NARRATOR: They were
never seen again.
Bruce Beveridge: None of the
guarantee group survived.
None of them.
Phil Gowan: The fact that none
of their bodies were ever found,
that there really
aren't accounts,
indicates that they didn't
really make any attempt to get
into lifeboats or
save themselves.
It doesn't appear that
any of them even tried.
Ian Frost: This is the postcard
my grandfather Artie Frost sent
to my father, Stanley, just
before he got on the Titanic
at Southampton and sailed away.
It says, How would you like
to be fishing off this pier?
Don't be having any more falls.
My father had just fallen off
his bike and taken the knee off
himself and he was hobbling
around at that time.
And that's the picture of
the pier at Southampton where
the Titanic was tied up.
This was the last word the
family had from him, this card.
And they never heard
from him again.
And that does something
to me when I say that.
NARRATOR: Of the 2,200 people
on Titanic's maiden voyage,
only 700 survived.
More than 1,500 died.
As early as 1912, families of
the victims proposed expeditions
to locate the wreckage.
Yet even as deep-sea
technology improved,
the Titanic remained
beyond reach for 73 years.
For Bob Ballard, it took a clue
from a Titanic survivor to show
him the way.
At the pier in New York,
where survivors came ashore,
Ballard meets the
grandson of Jack Thayer.
Jack was one of the last people
to jump from the stern of
the Titanic and live.
Ed Thayer: He and a friend
jumped from the same rail at
the same time.
His friend didn't
survive, he did.
So, it was just
probably by sheer luck.
And by finding an overturned
lifeboat and having some place
to sort of call
home for the night,
he was able to get out
of the water directly.
NARRATOR: Jack's account was one
of the first to say the Titanic
broke in half as it sank.
Bob Ballard: He said, The rumble
and the roar continued with even
louder distinct wrenching and
tearing of boilers and engines
from their beds.
Suddenly, the whole super
structure of the ship appeared
to split...
That's what led me to realize
that the ship broke in half
and dumped out its contents.
The story he told gave me
an idea on how to find her,
and that was not to
look for the Titanic,
but I would look for the debris
that came off the Titanic.
Because I knew its footprint
would be much larger
and predictable.
We knew the current so we knew
the debris field should be
north-south.
That's huge. 'Cause now
I have a line this way.
I search this way.
And sure enough, I picked up
the footprints and it led me
to the Titanic.
NARRATOR: But now that Ballard
has found the Titanic,
he faces a far more daunting
task: finding a way to protect
it and its thousands of
priceless artifacts.
Nikki: Got my menus! And a menu
holder. So that's good. Happy.
NARRATOR: As the Titanic
auction concludes,
the net sales add up to
over 300,000 dollars.
Andrew Aldridge: We had a really
motivated crowd here today,
very enthusiastic collectors
who're vying to buy some very
interesting pieces.
And we were very pleased
with how today went.
NARRATOR: The keys from the
Titanic sell for more than
55,000 dollars.
NARRATOR: Two guarantee group
artifacts go for more than
700 dollars each.
NARRATOR: They are letters of
condolence to the grieving
families.
Some of the items in the
auction are bound for museums.
Others will disappear
from public view.
As more and more items
fall into private hands,
there remains a key storehouse
for Titanic artifacts:
the ship itself.
And it's only getting easier
to reach what was once
an inaccessible depth.
David Gallo: Much of the
technology we use today to
explore in the ocean, those are
the grandchildren of the tools
we used on Titanic.
NARRATOR: This technology used
to be the exclusive domain
of elite oceanographers...
but those days are numbered.
David Gallo: Today, if
you've got the money,
it's very easy to go out and
find a ship, to find a robot,
get the cables, get a crew
together to go look at some
place like Titanic.
Let's face it, Titanic's
1,000 miles from New York,
it's 400 miles
from Newfoundland,
pretty hard to enforce
that site so far away.
Bob Ballard: There's
no international laws.
Any rogue organization
could go out there.
I'm mostly concerned about the
technology now to get inside.
And that's where the
preservation's the highest,
and most of the
contents are there.
NARRATOR: After
decades of waiting,
an international treaty and U.S.
legislation are now on the
table-and could start protecting
the ship as early as 2012.
Bob Ballard believes the
same ROVs that make it easier
to reach the Titanic, could
also make it easier to police.
Bob Ballard: Do I expect others
to go after artifacts from
the Titanic, covertly
or quietly? Yes.
Now, is there technology
that we could build sentries?
Absolutely.
Could we have guards?
Yes, easily.
NARRATOR: In fact, a pilot
project in the Pacific will
allow robots to constantly
monitor the ocean floor-a system
that could someday provide
24-hour security for
the Titanic.
But to Ballard, any solution
starts with the people most
affected by the tragedy.
Bob Ballard: How would you like
the site treated in the future?
Fred Parkes: I would like
it to be left as it is.
That's my uncle's graveyard.
And you don't desecrate a grave
Deirdre: I know my
great-grandfather, Roderick,
he's down there.
That's his grave.
And I know my grandmother was
extremely adamant that it should
not be touched, the graves
of all of them shouldn't be
tampered with...
Bob Ballard: Every person
I've spoken to that has any
relationship to the
Titanic, have all said,
Please protect this ship.
Johnny: And, you know, my
grandfather remembered being at
the launch and I can still hear
his booming voice saying it
should be left to rest in peace.
Bob Ballard: That's my hope.
Certainly all the survivors,
when I first found her,
there were several survivors
that were still alive,
and they all felt the same way.
Johnny: It's really important
that it's left as a memorial,
as a monument to the great
work that went on in Belfast.
NARRATOR: In downtown Belfast,
a monument stands in honor
of 22 local men who lost their
lives on April 15th, 1912.
Nine of them belong to
the guarantee group.
Bob Ballard: I didn't really
get touched by the Titanic until
I found it.
You know, I'm a scientist and
I looked at it as a technical
thing and, but when
we found it, that was,
it really hit me
and I was surprised.
NARRATOR: For the
guarantee group,
and for over a thousand others
who died on the Titanic,
this ship is their grave.
Every inch is sacred ground.
Every artifact...a memorial.
Bob Ballard: You know,
my feeling is that if
you can't protect the Titanic,
there is nothing in the sea
you can protect.
So, that's why I want
to stand my ground.
We're not done until
it's protected.